cancel culture claiming a new victim
teen vogue editor-in-chief
alexie mccammond forced out just days
before
even starting her new job after staffers
revolted over derogatory tweets she
wrote 10 years ago
when she was a teenager mccammond
apologized for them in 2019
and then again when this scandal
surfaced her old colleague at axios
jonathan swann saying things
are getting out of hand i was just
really
sad to see this happen i've worked with
her for four years
she doesn't have a racist bone in her
body if we can't
as an industry accept somebody's
sincere and repeated apologies for
something they tweeted when they were 17
years old
i mean what are we doing kaylee
kaylee i want to go to you first on this
to be clear these were
some of them tweets that she said when
she was 17.
does this just go too far oh absolutely
sandra i mean i think there's no denying
we are in the craziest
period period culturally i mean think of
what happened on the bachelor you know
you had a girl named rachel
who was canceled after giving a sincere
and heartfelt apology
then you go and you have chris harrison
who's cancelled for giving a comment
about someone else who was canceled and
saying let's show grace
and he hit the nail on the head he then
apologized for that by the way but he
hit the nail on the head by using the
word
grace we have to give people an
opportunity to have redemption
she did something dumb when she was 17
said something dumb she apologized
but if an apology is not enough what is
enough i'd ask the gods of cancel
culture
if you can't apologize and be forgiven
what do they need to do what are the
next steps is it public vlogging i mean
what what are we going to do she
apologized
move on let her have a job and a life
that's a good question jesse
i support public vloggings i could name
several people i'd like to vlog right
now
um i do feel bad for her because i'm a
very compassionate person she's lost her
job her boyfriend's lost her job
i would give her a job if she would work
for me but she probably hates me and
would never work
for me at all so that's fine but it does
seem like the left are starting to eat
their own and that usually signals the
end
of something like this i have a feeling
canceled culture might be winding down
and cultural revolutions that usually
indicates that time is running out
it does seem to me that we only can
cancel people because of the internet
before the internet
you couldn't dig into someone's past can
say ah 96 you said that
because there was no internet now i
think people are realizing
that maybe it's not such a good idea to
write down
every thought that goes through your
head on the internet
so everyone can see it you're just
giving
all these internet assassins more stuff
to shoot at
so maybe the the novelty of writing down
every joke you think might be
funny when you're 17 not a good way to
live life
it's a good it's a good lesson continued
lessons learned right one
it wasn't just the staffers that were
going after her by the way
it was the advertisers that then started
going after
teen vogue in the wake of this
controversy uh ulta beauty
burt's bees major advertisers with teen
vogue
they suspended their campaigns with the
publication
so there was a lot of money on the line
too here
that's exactly right so i think you have
to put that in context it was and for
them it was like a business decision
but the uh you know i mean to me i i
really
do believe in forgiveness and i i think
that you think about this as a juvenile
you know juveniles make mistakes we all
i just think everybody who's you know 16
17 you do crazy stuff
yeah but if even if it's a criminal act
sandra
in the courts they give you a separate
set of rules with more grace because
it's tried as a
you're tried as a juvenile and so here i
think
so you don't think she should have been
well i think the business decision is
separate from all this talk about cancel
culture i think
you know ultra ultra beauty and burt's
bee and
those are million dollar deals for conde
nast and what the head of conde nast
said in a statement was
that not only was the staff upset but he
said the readers
of their magazines uh took offense at
this and
they they were feeling blow back from
not only the advertisers but the readers
and the staff that's a lot
and so i think they had to make a
decision but i do think that
you know a moment of grace for someone
who was so young i just hope this is a
difficult
memory as she rises to much higher
things in life
because she was pretty accomplished she
had already done a lot that led up to
her getting this position
greg greg did you ever send any
questionable tweets when you were 17
years old
try 37 47. all right before i get on my
rant because i'm going to get on a rant
can we just say what an awful brand teen
vogue is
it's not really for teens and it has
nothing to do with vogue how do the
editors
editors at vogue cope with the fact that
team vogue is basically marxist
agit prop if you actually read it it's
child abuse
imagine like teen popular mechanics just
covering gardening
just totally just not even covering what
they're what they're called or
teen good housekeeping we're just gonna
do gender issues
that's what they've hijacked they
actually hijacked it and nobody talks
about it
okay we predicted this would happen it
was okay remember how okay it was when
it was only white people getting
canceled
but now you have a young black talented
woman getting cancelled
is this practice still worth it is it
still worth it if you could take down
10 other white people but you have to
sacrifice one young black woman who may
who probably doesn't deserve it
so this gets to my big question and i'm
so disappointed juan and you because
because where are the mentors right
where are the men like joy reid was
nearly fired
for uh blatant bigoted homophobic
blog post that she initially denied she
wasn't fired she was protected by her
network
possibly because they needed a quote
patina of diversity
her phrase but given her experience and
her success
shouldn't she have the guts to demand
condi nast
stick to their guns and fire their damn
news staff because they can
and protect this young woman who has
done did only did something wrong which
is everything
what about don lemon don lemon has a
voice
he's successful he's black why doesn't
he come to the aid
where are where are the mentors of color
who are defending these people lastly i
said this before the achilles heel
are corporations they are cowards
the actual mob is very very tiny but the
what the mob has is that they're
immovable and that scares people
ten people can feel like a hundred and
so you say oh my god the
advertisers are scared they're scared of
nothing and
everything same goes for viewers you
don't know how many viewers or
writers readers there are that are upset
so this is all a
giant mirage created by some very loud
voices
they if some company just stood up once
just stood up once and said you know
what we're sorry
but the newsroom has to go we believe in
this woman
she can hire the people that she wants
they might be all people of color
but you people you narrow-minded weirdo
mob
get the hell out of her here are your
boxes get out
but connie nast they're a bunch of
cowards they're pathetic and disgusting
yep exactly greg this has nothing to do
with race
you know greg this has nothing to do
with race i don't think it's right to
bring race into this
okay juan way to miss the point
i said stand up stand up for people
stand up for people don't go hey
you said you said you said where are the
the black mentors i don't think that's
what this
is about correct it's not about you i
think okay go okay
okay okay okay john jonathan swann a
white brit who can get who can you you
can't find anything whiter than a swan
he's the guy that's standing up he's the
guy
we're all gonna rely on jonathan swann
coming up